eid software's doom reboot is coming  very soon you might even say it's  impending bad puns aside doom releases  for ps4 xbox one and pc on May  thirteenth if that's too far off for you  I've got better news Bethesda will also  be providing a beta at some point before  launch it's not just the standard game  launching and may either for 120 bucks  you can get the collector's edition that  comes with a 12-inch statue of the  revenant and that's not just the leo  dicaprio movie it's one of Doom's  toughest monsters the collectors edition  also packages the game in a steel case  and you can pre-order any version of  doom to unlock the demon multiplayer  pack the doom reboot looks promising and  we don't have to wait much longer to see  if it lives up to the hype keep your  sights on gamespot for whenever bethesda  makes more announcements we're waiting  to hear about that beta 2